-You look fantastic.
Juno, thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
I'm so excited.
I can't believe this
is all real.
-We have so much to talk about.
-Mm-hmm.
-First off, I want to talk about
"The Offer."
This is on Paramount+.
This is the story of how
"The Godfather" got made.
I didn't know any of
these stories going into it.
Did you?
-No, neither did I.
I knew nothing.
Like, the fact that
the amount of hurdles,
the amount of complications,
the amount of [bleep]...
-Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-...that was thrown
at everybody.
-Even if you whisper it,
you still can't say it.
Yeah, it's interesting.
-Of shindigs that were
thrown at the production
that ultimately created one of
the greatest films of all time
was something that, yeah,
I really knew nothing about.
-Yeah. I, like --
I didn't know that --
I didn't know how
important your --
-They didn't want
Francis Ford Coppola, yes?
-They didn't want Francis Ford
or Marlon Brando.
-No.
And Al Pacino almost got fired.
These are all the people
that I --
They make me want to do
this job, you know?
-Isn't that wild?
-Yeah, it was crazy.
-If you think about --
You never know what goes into
what and how much work goes
into everything.
Like, that's "The Godfather."
-And the time and the passion
and the persistence
and that Al Ruddy, played by the
extraordinary Miles Teller --
-Yeah, he's great.
-Just -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love him. I love him.
-Now, you two together, come on.
Can we just even
talk about "Ted Lasso"
for a second, please?
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
It is a global --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Second Emmy nomination for you.
-It's so crazy.
-Yeah.
What was it like,
the first Emmys?
Did you go, "Oh,
wow, this is a big deal" or
"People are starting to watch"?
-It was so surreal.
It was -- I think you never --
can ever guess that anything
like that would happen.
And then the fact that the show
got nominated a lot of times
last round of Emmys
and that I got to go with
Hannah Waddingham,
who is one of my best friends
in the entire world.
-She is amazing.
By the way, she can sing,
by the way.
-She can sing. She can dance.
She can cuddle.
She can make you laugh.
She can make you cry.
She's got -- I love to just
lay in her chest.
-Yeah. That's so funny.
-Yeah
And we -- I waited for her,
because she --
We arrived at different times.
And when we walked
into the room,
our category was up first.
And I kid you not, she
literately sat and went, "Up!"
And I was like,
"You've got to go up.
Don't sit. Go, go."
And it was this immediate --
And then her speech.
-That was great.
Aww! You got such a good ca--
I mean, did you --
Backstage, you were saying,
"Yeah, I didn't know if
I could be funny
or I didn't think that --"
Like, you're a dramatic actor.
-I was known definitely
more for --
Yes, you know, I've played,
like, lesbian werewolves.
I've played --
-That will get you typecast.
Yeah.
-Yeah. Well, I've spent quite
a lot of time in trailer parks,
too, you know,
going through some [bleep]
-Yeah.
-Some stuff.
-Whisper it.
-Going through some stuff.
-Please, whisper it.
Thank you.
Please, just if you're going to
say it, whisper it, yeah.
It goes right under the censors.
They don't even know.
-Whoo!
-But who cast you?
Jason Sudeikis?
-Well, he sent me a text.
And there was this moment where
I thought, "Oh, gosh.
This is going to be awkward,
because I'm pretty sure
he has text the wrong actress.
And I'm going to have to write
back and be like,
"Yo, this is Juno Temple.
I don't know if you
actually know who I am."
-Yeah. You sent the wrong text,
but it sounds like a great part.
-Yeah, I'm super into
reading it.
Yeah, yeah. Let's definitely
talk about it later.
And it wasn't a mistake.
And I think that, you know,
he has this ability
with a lot of people
that were cast in the show
to see something
in all of us that we didn't
necessarily think
we had in us at all.
That being said,
a lot of the times,
I'm telling jokes on
"Ted Lasso."
I don't know
they're a joke, so...
-Well, good.
That adds to the mystique.
-Definitely.
-Yeah.
-And also because we get a lot
of ever-changing dialogue
and the fluidity of kind of
keeping our brains working
and things like that.
Because Jason comes from
the world that you do,
of "Saturday Night Live,"
where you guys are very quick at
learning anything that is
handed in front of you,
where I am used to sticky-tab
every single sentence
I'm going to say,
and I highlight it with
matching highlighters
to the sticky tab,
which tells me
what day I'm shooting, when,
where my character's at,
where it was two weeks ago.
It's a whole thing.
-No, all we do is
look at the cue cards.
It's all written over there.
You've got to get cue cards.
-Do you have some?
-You have to get
cue cards, yeah.
-Can I take some?
-Juno, do you understand --
Like, do you feel
what you've done and what you're
doing for the world?
Because people love you.
I hope you know this.
Like, do people tell
you how much they love you?
You're a part of their world.
Do people come up
to you and say,
"Hey, thank you" or "I love you"
or "You make me laugh"
or anything?
-Yeah. You know what?
Sometimes, they do, actually.
And that's something that I --
With this show,
it feels so special because you
get to go, "I'm a fan, too."
I love being a part of the show.
But there was
this beautiful moment.
Me and Hannah
were doing press for --
it was for Season 2 --
when we were filming Season 2,
so a lot of it was on Zoom.
And we were doing a Zoom thing.
And this lovely woman
was interviewing us,
and she just said to us both
that she was proud to show
this show to her daughter
when she grew up
because it was so important to
see two women who really
actually are best friends
and who root for each other
in a way that is genuinely about
seeing the other one
blossom and be the best
that they can be
and support each other,
but also call each other out
when necessary.
Your girlfriends are
so important.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Juno Temple in
"Ted Lasso."
Take a look at this.
-That baby sucks.
-You don't have to
say that to me.
-I'm not just saying it.
I'm serious.
That baby's whack.
I hate it.
-I love you.
-I love you, too.
I'm here for you,
whatever you need.
-I know.
-I won't leave your side.
-Jones!
-Sassy! Oh, my God!
Oh! Hi!
-There you go right there.
Juno Temple, everyone.
"Ted Lasso" is on Apple TV+.
Check out "The Offer"
on Paramount+.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Demi Lovato.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.